you
let's try it again I have the type of
position the type okay I have been I've
been playing this a lot the Kings Indian
attack against the monster and sometimes
I'm successful at getting the pawn up to
f5 oh let's let's do this move close the
center that's the first order of
business
all right let's throw a question here
drop the Queen back now sometimes this
could actually turn out to be a very
clean type of win what what a stunning
move d5 really oh my goodness what am I
missing as the computer just gone crazy
Dickie five who does d5 oh my goodness
is there gonna be just Knight takes here
Queen takes wow what a cool move is this
some opening trap yeah initially as I
was thinking a c6 but pawn takes Knight
takes pawn takes Knight there's gonna be
a knight sack and after Queen takes on
d5 this is gonna be brutal Wow what
about I take like this though and if
Knight takes then I play Bishop g2 let's
see what it has no yeah you see that man
oh man keep that in mind let's die I'm
too impatient to just wait to see this
one
what a cool sequence of moves d5 keep
that one in mind Wow okay so my idea was
Bishop g2 it does allow a knight here I
could defend with night a3 but these
Knights are very annoying
do I need to keep him out of there my
knight here how do I kick the knight out
of the b4 square it's very annoying
mmm I think I need to do that but it's
very scary okay
okay now the knight has to go away okay
maybe I could still do all right
okay the smoke has cleared certainly was
very scary for a little bit I was gonna
get slaughtered immediately oh maybe it
um you know it likes having a space
advantage and it would be okay I think
it would allow a situation where I think
you would see that Bishop takes Knight
is a favoring black but I think I'm
gonna do it
after takes Knight here I'm gonna go for
that opposite color Bishop ending okay
f5 I do this and I saw this check but
I'm okay with King f1 here I'm also
seeing this and I think this is okay for
me I'm using him as defense for my own
King now I have to be concerned about a
rook playing here this is actually my
only concern King F 1 2 G 2 as soon as I
moved this Bishop here this pawn aloof
he's going nowhere ever not right now at
least King here you see rook here is
gonna be very scary yeah I have to be
cautious King G to rook here if I take
the rook there's Queen check and then
pawn takes yeah King G to rook III if
pawn takes there's Queen check King f 1
and then pawn takes that's just too much
so I can't play King G 2
maybe I need to do this maybe I need to
move my bishop here right now to stop
rook to e3 oh man
then my king is gonna have to take a
hike
I think if I play my bishop to e4 pawn
push is probably gonna be played as
otherwise Queen f3 is quite solid
so Bishop b4 pawn here I think I have to
play like Queen here and then run all
the way over here am I pretty sure I
mean Brooke III King G two rookies free
maybe I just don't take the rook yeah I
just I'm just not gonna take the rook ah
didn't go there I love that let's trade
a pair of rooks okay so I was seeing a
ghost there I guess all right now we're
gonna trade oh now I could do this move
hang on can we get some more trade
bishop efore I'm okay with that
it won't do this move now aha
I got you right where I want you right
where I want you
I think I want to trade a little bit
more more trades is what I'm looking at
my bishop can't move okay
ah you're shuffling now you're shuffling
cuz you don't know what you want to do
and you're weakening your position
that's what it does sometimes it feels
like it needs to do something and it
can't really do anything how about this
I'm not even sure what it's doing maybe
this is a way to make Prague oh hang on
let's get back here that's so fast let's
try this 13 seconds
oh that queen is getting active I should
be okay though just babysit that for a
little bit okay I'm alright with that
let's trade get my King back over here
right here is where you belong actually
bishop here am i not picking up that
pond one day eleven seconds
see the queen is never gonna leave
defense our pressure of be too so I
think I have another drop I want it yeah
it's shuffling back and forth I want to
get more though maybe I could activate
my queen no not really
I check in here hmm
get my Bishop back on before you know
what it might do I play Queen here
that's wrong okay I have pressure there
but it's gonna have pressure here soon
my Queens active Queens getting more
active okay
ship here maybe I don't even know what
that's doing it's a threat against b2
again pressure in a four ah okay really
um no what I want to do I want to win
that pawn my bishop back on e4 I'm
threatening c6 and now g6 less than 10
seconds i King up uh not sure
come over in this direction have my king
defend that pond one of these things oh
I think I see a plan Queen C for it's
stupid in the opposite colored bishop
bending yes love that move
take this pine ok have at least a draw
at least let's do that and then and then
what something do something and do it
fast
that's the plan don't what that can get
too crazy actually he's getting crazy
crazier than I would have liked oh boy
oh boy
the king is entering the king is
definitely entering and I'm gonna be
dropping some material I have to just
bail out and go for the draw here it's
just not happening ah just throw my
bishop here
sitting on to that guy
yeah this is gonna be a dry think am I
gonna end up in maybe you just do back
and forth here try for something more is
it really gonna be stupid and allow me
to win it might do that now I'll just
accept the job oh yeah that deep that
deep on I should gotten rid of him at
the cost of giving up one of my own puns
no I wanted more I wanted more than that
you